in Hamburg Germany has rejected the
plying for the Olympic Games once again
I'm going to talk about this with me how
Vespa chairman of the board of the
German Olympic sports Confederation
welcome my Vespa thank you hats and
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the DW
interview my name is Thomas pan mr.
Vespa you were one of the founding
members of Germany's green party you
belong to what was called the Rihanna
wing what does the realistic politicians
say today this second refusal after
Munich has Germany parted ways with the
Olympic movement at least in terms of
hosting the games as Vivian naturally
fight of course we will carry on and
continue to try to embody the Olympic
ideals Abba mateesah entitled not this
decision by the people of Hamburg makes
it clear that we in Germany won't have
the opportunity to host the Olympic
Games again for a while pila also he can
subdue a food us that makes us very sad
we're very disappointed but this was the
decision a close decision but a clear
one I don't give isn't kenapa enshrining
of it you may declare it said that the
world's youth meets at the Olympics you
have four children what do they say
about the Hamburg decision he's in
theater all their sad after all it's
their fathers defeat my middle son an
ardent fan of the Armenia bielefeld
soccer team wrote me papa this isn't new
to you we Armenia fans are familiar with
this we lose a lot you just have to get
back up again afterward then with one
interview often see you were personally
very involved in this you fought for it
so how do you feel angry disappointed
enticed you disappointed yes but not
angry endorsed yeah very disappointed
but now we have to analyze it what were
the causes the preparations were
outstanding Oxford e1 f1 we had a very
high voter turnout for a referendum
justo
fifty percent in terms of intensity the
mobilization in Hamburg was beyond
comparison with what there was two years
ago in Munich it was much greater much
more intense yak-9 Quincy and we had a
concept that was not only praised in
glowing terms internationally but also
really had no opponents in Hamburg we
had a vision for Hamburg that was simply
great that's not what led to failure
cited about but the Olympics are not
responsible for Urban Development they
have to be worthwhile in themselves
choices that's absolutely right the
Olympics are the biggest sports event in
the world causes sport fest and Bob on
but the international olympic committee
wants everything that's built for the
olympics to still be needed and used
after these 17 days of olympics and 12
days of Paralympics not these in zip
ting Tong Olympian Swift and Paralympics
that's one of your arguments it pays off
but if that's true then you ought to be
able to attract private investors
shouldn't you yeah mine either isn't it
what got short shrift in the public
discussion is that if you look at the
costs solely of carrying out the games
at the projected prices of 20-24 that
would have been 3.4 billion euros for
that's yet goo visa and this sum would
be covered by the IOC subsidy of 1.7
billion dollars plus the proceeds of
ticket sales merchandising and national
sponsorships in past olympics there's
always been a profit but and it would
have been here to these and giving
probably what we have out here with
kabli your champions the Champions
League held its final in Berlin without
asking for public money why do the
Olympics have to demand public subsidies
by the Olympian spot you can't compare
the Olympic sport disciplines with
soccer first soccer is the most popular
sport of all and has lots of financial
possibilities phoenixian Mukhlis second
not the Olympics 44 world championships
are carried out in 17 days with the
Paralympics you have another 20
championships
very message often in seen tagging and
in this period the spotlight is on
athletic disciplines that unlike soccer
haven't had a stage to present
themselves on for four years mundo sheet
some foods bodies on this stage was set
up in Los Angeles and in Atlanta without
tax money why shouldn't that be possible
here in Germany that's the only story
goes it's not true that it was done
there without tax revenue but LA and
Atlanta also had big corporate sponsors
the Atlanta Olympics were even called
the coca-cola games but as I said you
have to distinguish between the costs of
the games and the infrastructure the
costs of carrying out the games don't
need public subsidies but other measures
like building a new subway line or
developing a city district these
projects can't be amortized within four
weeks of olympic and paralympic games
they were a vision for the future that
would have been useful for hamburg for
decades super sweet because we had seen
to it that handbook notes did not much
let's talk about what the decision means
for you personally it must feel like a
severe political defeat view a sports
political defeat that the people of
hamburg rejected the games is this worse
for you than the political defeat in
2005 when your time as deputy state
premiere of the state of North
rhine-westphalia came to an end I didn't
for not have is fine Ben there's what
use does in a Democrat well that's how
it is in a democracy you win some and
you want to win as often as possible and
you lose some and then it's all about
how you deal with this defeat you know
how you get back up again and so this
was quite similar avenida laga dena
trulia oh also it's a bitter defeat to
which external factors contributed but
of course we made some mistakes
ourselves from the sports science folks
bought so for example they have if you
like of it well maybe we didn't make the
funding context clear enough maybe we
didn't convey the Olympic values
emotionally enough
davita but you know in the discussion in
recent days we've heard both we boogie
rock obviously yes we've heard criticism
that we were too enthusiastic that we
appeal to emotions too much and provided
to little concrete information but we
also heard the opposite criticism that
we were too occupied with
number-crunching too sober and showed
two little spirits will have to analyze
this carefully before drawing
conclusions Vivian does easy as Rockford
you off about and listen well done or
for all t see you spoke of the Olympic
values faster higher further how
idealistic does one have to be to
celebrate top athletic achievements in
times of state-sponsored doping in
Russia and other nations even benzene my
nilla who are like you're mistaken if
you think that faster higher farther are
the Olympic values the Olympic values
are respect tolerance fairness
achievement and internationalism these
are Olympic values that are connected
with the games and part of this of
course is a zero tolerance policy toward
any form of fraud and that includes
doping doping as well so if I may put it
this way what we recently saw in track
and field from Russia is anti Olympics
at equal intervals and gezina that's why
as far as track and field goes the
Russian Association has been suspended
for the moment from the olympic games in
rio de janeiro in the view design near
what yes by vascular didn't get
suspended yet but you are also an
athlete in private life doesn't it
bother you that on the one hand there is
the noble ideal but on the other hand
when you see the competition's when you
see Usain Bolt running don't you have
your doubts that this is a real
achievement nice toys business he didn't
you know I've I reject this blanket
suspicion to assume that someone must be
doping just because he runs faster than
others that's just too simplistic
there's a very efficient control system
it's true not everything is caught a lot
is caught later because the blood
samples taken at the Olympic Games are
frozen for eight years I think now it's
for 10 years so that analytic methods
developed later can find these banned
substances and of course there is some
fraud I don't doubt that but you have to
prove it before you can accuse or
suspect someone that's all no flies and
i think that the penalty that the
anti-doping system imposes on athletes
namely an immediate four year suspension
it's very effective internationally
better that's in diesel for example when
spa internets in a decent shawnzy a
versa i sir the next games will Russia
be without its track and field athletes
the whole thing as it stands today yes
but if Russia complies with the
conditions imposed by the world
anti-doping agency and changes its
system and cleans up its national
anti-doping agency and its track and
field Association does the same then
it's possible the suspension will be
revoked I was addressing the hobby
athlete maker Vespa when your Achilles
tendon was not yet torn you used to take
part occasionally and semi marathons so
how long a stretch will it be before
Germany can dare apply for the olympic
games again honk as a lingo well I think
it'll be longer than a marathon as a
talk about thing at the moment to be
honest we aren't thinking about it at
all there's no application on the
horizon it's God when you've just had to
accept such a defeat even though your
proposal was great one that corresponded
exactly to the Olympic reform agenda
2020 namely with modest transparent
flexible games that aren't bombastic as
they have sometimes been elsewhere well
you don't start thinking about the next
application right away buddy nix the
parabola mr. fespa we always end our
interview with our three incomplete
statements that we ask you to complete
considering the decisions in hamburg and
munich the former East German top
athlete hiker Drexler called for an end
to referendums on such questions so
first
i as a green politician on the contrary
think mine and again mitten ducky you're
on the contrary already dictates my
answer I think that elements of direct
democracy are good but I don't think we
should use them to undercut our
representative democracy and those we
vote into Parliament and the government
alimentive valen indeed Allah Gilman
Baron Nico cylinder of them I'm second
as general secretary of the central
committee of German Catholics my brother
represents 26 million Germans yep I have
a good fortune as I like to joke that 27
million people are organized in sports
clubs and sports associations in the
German Olympic sport Confederation info
been this is how we tease each other in
my family but it's fun to mention
occasionally what's a lie I was much
Buscema my view that's an end it out 18
I wanted to turn the world upside down
and today I still do make investment
thank you very much you're welcome